the major muscles are well advanced and
the fetus is now moving survival muscles
such as those in the legs and jaw
developed more rapidly than other
muscles these key muscles are vital for
the animals survival once it leaves the
uterus this early movement serves as a
form of exercise for the developing
muscles it's also necessary to keep the
joints moving as they develop the fetus
doesn't move the joints will freeze the
ears are clearly visible the inner ear
has formed but the middle and external
ear are still growing
the dog-ear is far more sophisticated
than the human ear when a dog's ear is
pricked up the ear flap reflects sound
back into the ear canal enhancing the
hearing like when a human cups their ear
with their hand right now the ear canal
is plucked but when this Retriever is an
adult it'll be able to hear sounds far
beyond the range of human hearing
a dog can hear sounds of such high
frequency that to produce them a piano
would require an extra four octaves but
dogs don't actually make high pitched
sounds themselves so their hearing may
be linked to their hunting instincts